the Home Secretary controversially
called it an invasion more than 40 000
migrants have crossed the channel this
year and after weeks of leaks chaos
overcrowding reports of diphtheria and
the death of one Asylum seeker can I
welcome the Home Secretary today swella
bravaman admitted the government has
failed we have failed to control our
borders yes and that's why the Prime
Minister and myself are absolutely
determined to fix this problem but she
argued it's not her fault I'm very clear
at who's at fault it's the people coming
here legally and today's political
attacks were largely Blue on Blue let's
do a bit of role play I'm a 16 year old
orphan from an East African country
escaping a war zone and uh religious
persecution and I have a uh a sibling
legally in the United Kingdom at the
moment what is the safe and legal route
for me to come to United Kingdom well we
have
um an asylum system and people can put
in applications for Asylum how would I
do that
well you can
um uh you can you can do it through the
safe and legal routes that we we have
what schemes open to me well if you are
able to get to the UK you are able to
put in an application for Asylum I would
only enter the UK illegally then
wouldn't it
the manston processing center in Kent
that was at nearly three times capacity
has now been cleared
but thousands of migrants have been
moved across the country to hotels
costing taxpayers almost 7 million
pounds a day and angering some Tory MPS
this is a wrong-headed decision the
local police the local Council and I
have been misled and I have no
confidence at all that the home office
Circo or the minister himself have the
first clue of what they are doing in
relation to this Asylum Seeker
relocation the minister should consider
his position
Rishi sunak has said helping the home
office to tackle illegal immigration is
his top priority Liz truss and Boris
Johnson said similar things but therein
lies the political danger because if you
make little to no progress on your key
commitment well you failed at your own
test
the fact that polls suggests labor are
now ahead on the issue of immigration is
very concerning for the conservatives
leaks are the leads to their problems
Joe Pike Sky News Westminster